the secret to my success has only been
consistency over time I just have not
quit I had one business model that shut
down not from anything that I did on my
own but just because I had a really
terrible health problem I had four
organs removed and three surgeries in 2
years and it brought me to my knees
literally I lost everything and I had to
start over again I took the lessons that
I learned up to that point and used them
to fuel me to Build a Better Business
and to build a better life for myself
there have been days there have been
moments there still are but the secret
is to not quit just to let those battles
become the lessons and stay consistent
over time because you can do it